bring in our panel josh crushauer is
politics editor for national journal
katie pavlich news editor at
townhall.com and former education
secretary bill bennett is with us
tonight so bill why don't you start us
off this was never meant to actually
advance the matter it was merely a name
taking exercise democrats think that
it's going to work in their favor in the
november election but will it
well it may work a little bit but they
have to frame the argument right and
this kind of fantasy stuff doesn't work
this was
paraphrase shakespeare full of sound and
fury and ominous warnings but coming to
nothing
really amounting amounting to nothing
this is the most difficult arguably the
most difficult issue in american
politics abortion when you go to the
states there are real issues to be
debated
but not the way they were doing it today
and not the way they're doing it on the
street
outside of the justices houses let me
just add that just before in this
channel a couple hours ago
your governor the redoubtable glen
yonkan was out saying we will protect
these justices we will have law
enforcement there and we will write the
attorney general to do his job and
enforce the law to protect them yeah
we'll talk more about that in just a
second there was an interesting moment
today katie
because that vote forced pennsylvania
senator bob casey who is adamantly
pro-life in fact his father the late
governor of the state of pennsylvania is
the casey in planned parenthood
versus casey he was forced to vote in
favor
of the measure and i'm wondering is is
that an indication that there's no room
to be pro-life in the democratic party
and and how might that play out in
november
yeah there is no room in the democratic
party to be pro-life uh they've taken
the position that they took you know it
was rare they wanted to be rare and safe
to have an abortion in the 90s to this
extreme measure that they voted on today
and for chuck schumer to put this on the
floor for a vote knowing it was going to
fail
it was quite interesting given the lack
of political traction that democrats
have been able to get on every single
issue that voters are concerned about
but i want to talk about the issue of
the democrats using this for the midterm
elections midterms of course are base
turnout elections that's why they're
doing this
but the truth is that they continue to
argue that this bill was about codifying
roe
that's absolutely not true this bill was
extreme it would wipe out basically all
state laws when it came to restricting
abortion the majority of americans
believed that abortion should be
restricted after 15 weeks it would force
religious institutions to
con conduct the procedure it also would
get rid of consent laws for parental
consent which 70
of the country uh supports and so for
democrats they're using this to get out
their base understanding that the rest
of the country really is not where they
are when it comes to unlimited a number
of months when it comes to abortion in
late term which the country does not get
on board with in any sense of the term
especially on the state level josh let's
talk a little bit about the security
issue that bill bennett brought up just
a second ago the governors of virginia
and maryland glenn younkin and larry
hogan did send a letter to the attorney
general asking him to take action the
attorney general apparently has directed
the u.s marshals service to help ensure
the justice's safety by providing
additional support to the marshal of the
supreme court and the supreme court
police but this action out in virginia
and in maryland and in washington d.c
protesting these justices at their homes
that that brings up the specter of what
happened to judge esther salas in uh
july of 2020 when a crazed person who
found out her address
shot and killed her son daniel now it's
not to say that these protests are going
to erupt in that but when you dox
supreme court justices and you publish
wide and large their addresses you leave
them open to potential danger here yeah
democrats are playing with fire here
when they refuse to unequivocally
condemn this pressure campaign at the
supreme court justice's own homes their
personal homes
in an attempt to pressure their decision
making on this upcoming case and keep in
mind the decision has not been made and
federal law is pretty clear that any
such you know harassment or or just uh
undue pressure on judges in particular
is against the law and i've been stunned
that you know you haven't seen clearer
rhetoric from joe biden from the white
house from gensake this is a
the democrats could get some political
attraction in in defending abortion
rights but they can't do it when they
sound extreme or they're defending the
most extreme elements within their own
base yeah on the subject of extreme a
lot of republicans bill as we switch
gears think that this disinformation
governance board is extreme they're
trying to take measures to prevent
funding it lauren bobert the republican
representative from colorado said i
don't think people are fully
understanding the severity of what a
ministry of truth organized by dhs truly
means this is stalin level this is mao
level this is the hill to die on
is it the hill to die on bill
well you know first of all it's entirely
inappropriate in a free country to have
something like this but you would think
this thing would be thrown out
immediately on the basis the fact that
the woman is being recommended to head
the
ministry of disinformation has been
wrong on everything
she got everything wrong she disinformed
on hunter biden she disinformed on
russian collusion and so on
this is another big fat target
democrats have presented for themselves
a real mistake we don't need it we don't
want it
and god knows i think we'll be spared it
of course we all know now we're very
familiar with that mary poppins video
that nina jankowicz did but we also have
a new tweet that has come to light via
the washington examiner in which he said
on november the 1st 2020 trump had not
won but two secret email servers to
communicate with an influential russian
bank unbelievable
katie that's disinformation
yeah that is disinformation and this is
not the only corner of the
administration where this disinformation
is coming from the incoming white house
press secretary uh karine gene pierre
also said that the georgia election was
stolen from stacey abrams and that
president trump wasn't a legitimate
president so there is this very serious
question about the biden administration
creating this new board not to you know
serve as a way to tamp down on
disinformation which used to be a term
that was reserved for homeland security
dealing with outside foreign influence
and information inside the united states
but to go after political enemies inside
the country without any recourse because
they're not elected and it's very
difficult to get through the bureaucracy
and understand what they're doing and i
would note that the dhs secretary can't
define what the mission is of the board
and therefore it's right for abuse i
wanted to ask josh about that in the 45
seconds we've got last the fact that
alejandro mayorkas knew so little about
all of this what does that say to you
not an encouraging sign john that
it doesn't seem like they vetted the the
per nina jankowicz the person who who is
going to be heading this disinformation
uh committee uh i mean and i i i if you
can't vet your own staff and you don't
see this stuff uh that that's clearly
been out there now for the last week
it's a real big red flag i would expect
that if republicans take back the house
uh in in november the if it still exists
by by 2023 there's going to be a lot of
oversight and it's not going to last
much longer all right well i assume that
they know a lot more about it now than
they did a week ago josh croshhauer
katie pablo
good to see you folks thanks for joining
us tonight have a great evening hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else